- [Joey] So pretty much
everyone knows that one guy,
who on New Year's Eve
proclaims to all of his friends
his ambitious plans to
go to the gym every day
or wake up at 7:00 am every
morning for the whole year.
And they go and buy new workout clothes,
install habit tracking apps,
and are elated by the prospect
of becoming that awesome person
they've always wanted to be.
In fact, they're so excited about it,
it's as if they actually,
you know, did something.
But before a single day is completed,
they'll bombard you with
incessant monologues
about all the benefits
they're going to experience
and how life-changing it's gonna be.
But you almost can't
help but roll your eyes,
because you know they're
just talking about it,
not actually doing it.
One of the things I've
learned over the years is
that nobody cares about what
you say you're going to do,
and you shouldn't either.
No matter how much you flap
your jaw, nothing moves,
and having ambition isn't special.
Almost everyone has ambition.
Whatever your goal in life is,
there are likely millions of other people
with that exact same goal,
unless you have like a really weird goal,
like performing a puppet show
on top of Mount Everest or something.
But telling somebody that
you're going to do something
isn't impressive to anyone in
any way and never has been.
And it never will be.
So instead of humble
bragging to your roommate
about how you're gonna start
taking the gym more seriously
or start eating clean from now on,
try giving your tongue a little rest
and actually get a few days, weeks,
or even months under your belt.
Learn to embrace the
process of pushing yourself
and achieving things
when nobody is watching
because after all, who are
you doing this for anyways?
Do you genuinely want to build a company,
or do you just crave the patronizing,
"Oh, that's cool man, good for you,"
that you get for mentioning it.
The way I see it,
there are only four types
of people in this world.
Those who talk the talk and walk the walk.
Those who talk the talk
and don't walk the walk.
Those who don't talk the
talk and don't walk the walk.
And finally,
those who don't talk the
talk, but walk the walk.
And I would argue that this final option
is the best option you
should strive towards,
because those who talk
the talk and walk the walk
are usually annoying,
and they brag about the
fact that they do things.
Those who talk the talk
and don't walk the walk
are even worse because they pretend
that they do all these things,
but they're just talking.
And the saddest of the
bunch, number three,
are those who don't talk the
talk and don't walk the walk,
pretty self-explanatory,
yeah, just a generally
uninspiring crowd to be around.
And number four,
those who don't talk the
talk, but walk the walk,
these are the coolest
people on planet earth.
This is the guy who's absolutely ripped,
but doesn't talk about it.
The guy who drives an insanely nice car,
but few people know what
he does for a living.
His lifestyle is proof, in and of itself,
of rigorous discipline, hard
work, patience, et cetera,
but he doesn't flaunt it,
unless it's with a legitimate
accountability partner
or group that you actually take seriously.
Speaking before you do
is just a useless step
in the way of actually doing.
Otherwise, you're just seeking validation
for something you haven't even done yet.
So here's a personal challenge from me,
go achieve something you've
always wanted to achieve,
something you've been
putting off for a long time,
and something that would
dramatically improve your life,
and when you're done, don't tell a soul.
I guarantee you
this will improve the
way you look at yourself.
It will bolster your self efficacy.
You'll carry around this confidence.
It's like your own dirty little secret,
and it'll permeate every
aspect of your being,
your interactions with other people,
and you'll secretly know
that you're a bad-ass,
and you didn't have to tell anybody.
If you like this video, be
sure to hit that like button,
and if you like videos
like these in general,
hit that subscribe button.
If you're a regular subscriber,
you might be confused
that you're not seeing my
face at the end of this video.
Basically, I'm having a bad hair day.
No, basically half of my
apartment is packed up,
and the background looks really bad,
so I just figured I'd keep it.
Yeah, you get it.
Next video, you might see my
face talking to the camera.
Okay, see you later.
(moody music)